in
houston they filled their gm position
and now they're looking for a head coach
there's a buzz out there that jim
caldwell the former colts and lions head
coach is the guy texans eventually going
to hire now they're adding names to the
dance card for interviews leslie frazier
we reported earlier today and i've seen
others have confirmed it the bills
defensive coordinator and former head
coach of the vikings will interview for
the texans opening
what they need to do now strategically
and this is a team that has shown
in recent months that it is rife with
dysfunction
they need to
get control of their situation and first
and foremost come up with a way to
improve the relationship with
quarterback deshaun watson this
situation continues to disintegrate and
watson i'm told on vacation not doing
anything not even really thinking about
it until his vacation ends at that point
he will deal with it there was some i
think the phrase was informed
speculation yesterday that watson would
accept the trade to the dolphins look
watson has a no trade clause and that
doesn't mean he can't be traded by
either side that means he's only traded
if he says okay he's got the ultimate
hammer over any trade talks because if
the texans are talking to and i'll just
throw out a team the seahawks not that
that would ever happen he could say i
don't want to go to seattle no veto next
it's like when elaine and joe rifkin
were trying to figure out his next name
he's got the ultimate veto power over
his next destination so maybe he would
go to miami why wouldn't he if he could
get an opportunity to go there
considering they've got such a great
team think of how good they would be if
they had him at quarterback there will
be other teams that he may be interested
in but the first
challenge for the texans if they truly
want to keep him and they've put out the
word they want to keep him you've got to
repair the relationship with deshaun
watson the coaching hire is the thing
that will repair the relationship and so
much has happened over the course of the
past few days i can't remember what
we've talked about and what we haven't i
think we've already talked about the
idea that sean watson recommended eric b
enemy for the job in houston and the
texans refused to interview him i mean
if they really want to create the
impression they're placating desean
watson they'll interview eric b enemy
and potentially hire him although that
would be i think too much public
capitulation to an employee of an
organization they probably can't do that
but if there's someone else that they
believe can come in who's got
the exact you know teams are always
looking for the exact opposite of the
last guy they had and bill o'brien was
his fire and brimstone old school
f-bombing northeastern guy if they get
someone whose demeanor is extremely calm
and quiet and easy going and there's an
even keel
that could be the thing that resonates
with deshaun watson now the worst case
scenario for the texans is you hire a
coach specifically with the idea that
he's going to fix the relationship with
the quarterback
and then he doesn't
that's the thing that the texans need to
figure out before they hire a coach
how far gone
is this
is it fixable
with the right coach
if it isn't
then don't hire a coach with an eye
toward
repairing the relationship with sean
watson because at the end of the day you
can end up without desean watson and
with a head coach who wouldn't have
hired but for the fact that you wanted
someone who could fix the relationship
with sean watson so
big
philosophical decision that needs to be
resolved in houston and what makes it
more compelling from our purposes and
maddening from the purposes and
perspectives of a texans fan
there's just a sense that the texans
currently
don't know what they are doing
we have figured out what we are doing by
way of getting sharing williams back
this is effort number three sharina i
know how much you've heard of what i was
saying about the texans in their
coaching situation and the dysfunction
that is there but they've got to get rid
of this dysfunction and look i'm sorry
people like why do you keep going after
jack easter but i keep going after jack
easter because he deserves to be gone
after because he has no business running
a football operation and all this
dysfunction traces to him the fact that
deshaun watson wants out traces to him
and maybe if it comes down to it hey and
ask any football fan in the world
would you rather have to show watson or
jackie's to be employed by your team
there won't be a single person out there
not related to jack easter be who says
jack easter be and i think some of the
people related to jack easterby would
probably still say desean watson shireen
yeah you're exactly right mike and they
have to make desean wants watson want to
be there that's the key they have to
make him happy and so they need to hire
a head coach that he's on board with i'm
sorry but sometimes that's the way it
works when your star quarterback wants a
certain coach and wants to be happy and
it has expressed his displeasure you
have to make him happy you have to make
him want to be there i know people are
saying hey they pay him a lot of money
to play football go play football it
doesn't matter who the head coach is
aaron rodgers didn't have a say i get
that but he also can force his way out
of houston mike and they have to make
sure that he's on board with whoever
they hire or he is going to want out and
he is just going to be as you said just
an employee and do the bare minimum mike
well and i don't even think he'll he'll
do the bare minimum and just be an
employee i think he's going to say i'm
done i'm out i'm out i'm not showing up
find me i don't care take back mona's
money i don't care i'm out
because he's it's it's easier for him to
do that because if you don't show up
it's easier to stay away than once you
show up with jalen ramsey a couple of
years ago once he decided he wanted out
and ramsay is instructive on this
because they're represented by the same
agent david mullighetta ramsay couldn't
walk out once you report
your leverage is much more difficult to
exercise if you walk away
ramsay had no choice but to basically
you know be injured or injured or
whatever the case may be and agitate to
get out watson's in a much better
position where he can just say look i'm
done it's over i've crossed that bridge
in my mind i'm not coming back again you
need to accept that you need to make
decisions accordingly and that gets back
to what i was saying a few minutes ago
shireen
if hiring jim caldwell or leslie frazier
or some other coach with a very calm
even killed almost a tony dungy type of
a demeanor if that won't repair the
relationship the exact opposite of bill
o'brien if that won't repair the
relationship then why bother they need
to find out whether or not this can fix
it before they go down that path
yeah no question about it mike and it is
interesting some of the guys that
they've gotten because a lot of them
have been head coaches before
a lot of them are in their
early to mid 60s which is not what you
expect in this day and age in a coaching
search so
i know that nick casario is just getting
on board and just getting underway today
i think it's his first official day but
they've got a lot of work to do here
and a lot of it begins with again making
desean watson happy with whatever they
do with this coaching hire so he better
get to work and and better get in
contact with deshaun watson whether he's
in cabo or back home or wherever he is
but he better find deshaun watson and
figure out what the guy wants to be
happy
let me just repeat what i said last week
when cal mcnair the owner of the team
just shrugged at the idea that well i
tried to call desean watson but he's on
vacation he didn't call me back look
when the guy who signs your extremely
large checks tries to call you if you're
still interested in being employed by
that person you call him back the fact
that watson didn't take the call and or
immediately call cal mcnair back
probably answers the question for mcnair
as to whether or not deshaun watson has
crossed a bridge that he will not go
back across and he seems like the kind
of guy who is not going to play games
once he's done he's done
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports